das ist eine ecke der landes und
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd in
thüringen sozusagen der oberste
flügelmann der ofd erhöhte alexander
gauland hat ja hier auch nochmal quasi
eine bündnis offerte an die union
abgegeben
da waren sie etwas schneller vor zwei
wochen haben sie schon an mike mohring
gesagt sie würden eine
minderheitsregierung der cdu die ja viel
schwächer geworden ist in der oder
jedenfalls schwächer als die afg in
thüringen bei der wahl
sie würden eine solche
minderheitsregierung tolerieren dass
ausgerechnet von ihnen dieser vorschlag
kommt hat ja in der cdu viele verwundert
war das ein ernst gemeinter vorschlag
mike mohring als ministerpräsident in
thüringen zu tolerieren
wir haben eine einzigartige situation
nach den landtagswahlen in thüringen
eine situation die jetzt auch eine
staatspolitische verantwortung von allen
akteuren einfordert die wollen wir
erleben die wollen wir auch da stellen
wir sind eine bürgerlich patriotische
kraft die nach fünf jahren
parlamentserfahrung jetzt auch
verantwortung verstärkt verantwortung
übernehmen möchte wenn es in regierung
noch nicht funktioniert weil die anderen
politischen kräfte in diesem lande da
noch bedenken haben
da sind wir trotzdem bereit zu zeigen
dass wir gespräche offen sind und dass
wir ohne vor allen dingen vorbedingungen
diese gespräche reingehen
wir wollen über inhalte reden und nicht
über personen das ist leider eine
tendenz in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten in der bundesrepublik
deutschland haben
es wird zu viel über personen und zu
wenig über inhalte geredet zu viel über
machtoption von einzelnen funktionären
zu wenig über das wohl des landes das
wollen wir korrigieren und wie gesagt
wir stellen keine vorbedingungen wir
denken in alle richtungen ob das eine
minderheitsregierung ist ob das eine
expertenregierung ist wer dann
ministerpräsident wird das muss sich
dann aus den gesprächen ergeben
sicher ist nur dass bodo ramelow keine
mehr den touring merkel abgewählt worden
ist als eine ungewöhnliche situation
also eine partei die stärker ist einer
schwächeren partei anbietet sie darf
nicht nur den ministerpräsidenten
stellen man muss mit der afg gar nicht
koalieren noch mal wir sind bereit einen
großen schritt in richtung der union zu
tun
klar ist aber auch dass die union und
den türen gibt es zumindestens ein
zeichen der hoffnung die wir haben
der fdp politiker muss sich
grundsätzlich die frage stellen wo will
sie hin
wenn sie weiter einem links-grün bunten
zeit gas hinterherhechelt wie spätestens
unter merkel jetzt in den letzten jahren
und jahrzehnten
dann wird sie den weg der italienischen
christdemokratie gehen das ist der weg
in die politische bedeutungslosigkeit
oder sie reformiert sich sie besinnt
sich wieder für ihre bürgerlich
konservativen werte dann wäre sie in
zukunft auch einen koalitionspartner
wie gesagt wir wollen erstmal ins
gespräch kommen wir wollen über inhalte
reden
sie haben stichwort merkel schon gegeben
gesagt sie seien die cdu sei noch nicht
zu einem normalen bündnis bereit aber
wird sie das jemals bereit sein auch
wenn man bedenkt wie in ihrer partei
auch von ihnen zum beispiel über die
langjährige parteivorsitzende und
jetzige bundeskanzlerin gesprochen wurde
manchmal das gefühl die wird ja wie eine
aussätzige behandelt glauben sie dass
die cdu mit leuten wie ihnen mit der afg
tatsächlich politische bündnisse
eingehen will in absehbarer zeit die
alle parteien haben es in den letzten
jahren wird hin zugelassen dass diese
demokratie nicht mehr voll
funktionsfähig ist das hat damit etwas
zu tun dass der meinungs- korridor immer
enger geführt wurde
wir leben im augenblick im zustand einer
erstarrten konsensdemokratie konsens ist
gut und richtig man muss kompromissfähig
seien in einer demokratie man darf nicht
direkt mit dem konsens im gespräch
reingehen erst mal müssen sie
widerstreitender position auch durch
gekämpft werden natürlich alles im
rahmen des im parlamentarismus möglichen
und notwendigen und dann muss man
irgendwann zu kompromissen kommen im
augenblick ist es so dass die
altparteien innerlich in den zentralen
politikfeldern ob das die euro-rettung
ist die energiewende politik ist oder
die einwanderungspolitik ist kaum noch
zu unterscheiden sind dann sind wir
gekommen als ard haben alternative
positionen angeboten zum ersten mal
haben die menschen wieder etwas zu zu
wählen wir sind als gegner markiert
worden auch entsprechend hart mag man
markiert und haben uns auch entsprechend
hart zu wort gemeldet und ich glaube
nicht dass das diese demokratie
geschadet hat sondern eher zu einer
lebendigen verlebendigung des
politischen diskurses beigetragen hat
natürlich sind hier und da vielleicht
noch mal grenzverletzung passiert aber
ich möchte daran erinnern dass wir alles
neulinge waren als wir angefangen haben
vor sechs jahren fällt haben wir
manchmal noch überzogen aber dass frau
merkel diesem land schweren schaden
zugefügt hat davon bin ich persönlich
weiter an überzeugt dass diese dame
nicht gutes für deutschland so schnell
wie möglich in den verdienten ruhestand
geschickt werden muss davon sind wir als
fdp überzeugt
jetzt hat er zumindest gehört also in
den verdienten ruhestand geschickt
werden soll
sie haben von grenzverletzungen
gesprochen aber das waren ja
möglicherweise war es noch sehr viel
mehr als künstlerin wie weit muss die
afd dann auch auf die union zu gehen und
klammer auf muss sich für ein höcker in
der öffentlichkeit zukunft bei
öffentlichen äußerungen mehr mäßigen
naja ich bin ja einer der wenigen
politiker in deutschland die auch fehler
eingestanden haben
die er gemacht hat in den letzten jahren
ich habe zu der dresdner rede deutlich
stellung bezogen
das denkmal das scheint dem 1 das falsch
interpretiert worden ist daran möchte
ich gern erinnern da sind wichtige
themen in einem einer falschen
atmosphäre einfach vergeigt worden von
mir das ist aber der tatsache geschuldet
dass ich eben kein politik profi bin
aber ich glaube viele menschen im land
haben das mittlerweile auch verziehen
und sind eher dankbar dafür dass es auf
jeder kantige politiker gibt sicherlich
haben wir gelernt ich habe gelernt und
was die was den ausdruck angeht aber wir
sind wie gesagt auch hart angegriffen
worden und vergessen sie bitte nicht
dass das wir als afd und das sind ja
auch die ergebnisse von anfragen die die
bundestagsfraktion der afg an die
bundesregierung gestellt hat ganz
überproportional opfer oft opfer von von
gewalttätigkeiten sind gucken sie
hundertschaften von polizisten
wasserwerfer panzerfahrzeuge müssen
diesen bundesparteitag schützen unsere
wahlkreisbüros werden mit bomben
angegriffen ich krieg fast jeden tag
morddrohungen
das sind schon besondere belastungen die
vielleicht auch manchmal dann auch einem
einem bürgerlichen grundsätzlich
bürgerlich gestimmten menschen wie mir
eine gegenreaktion abfordern
aber wie gesagt ich denke sie sind auf
dem guten weg vielleicht ist das für die
af.de taktisch oder strategisch gar
nicht so schlecht dass er immer so
angefeindet wird wie heute dass er nicht
nur bei diesem parteitag so gewesen dass
sie so viele gegen den slot
demonstranten jetzt in hand in
braunschweig zu sammeln na ja also ich
denke dann die polizisten die draußen
ihren dienst tun müssen ich denke an die
vielen millionen euro steuergeld die
dieser großeinsatz der polizei kostet
ich denke und das haben wir mit unserer
landtagsarbeit den thüringen in allen 16
landtagen und im bundestag aufgeklärt
dass dieser linksextreme sumpf der da
draußen auch wieder sich versammelt hat
leider in vielen fällen noch durch
steuergeld über den sogenannten kampf
gegen rechts finanziert wird das sind
problemlagen den müssen wir begegnen und
dass es ist keine keine gute werbung für
uns wie gesagt wir nehmen diese
herausforderung an wir werden auch nicht
klein beigeben
aber hier ist es ist das land in
grundsätzlich schieflage geraten
hier muss die politik ansetzen
demokratie verhinderung darf nicht noch
mit steuergeld finanziert werden wenn
die cdu ihre offerte nicht annehmen
sollten
machen sie dann ihre drohung wahr die
sich schon am wahlabend in thüringen
angekündigt haben dass die afd dann beim
nächsten mal die absolute mehrheit
gewinnt also ich kann ja der union
prophezeien und das tun nicht nur recht
wenn die union sich nicht entscheidet
und außerdem aus dem prozess des
lavierens nicht herauskommt die union
ist ja mittlerweile bekannt dafür dass
sie jeden jeden inhalt der taktik zu
opfern bereit ist und vor allen dingen
auf den macht erwerb oder machterhalt
schielt das geht irgendwann nicht mehr
die lage im land wird viele menschen
immer deutlich erkennbar eine
schlechtere viele menschen wären
mittlerweile und ich denke jetzt gerade
an die neuen entlastungs meldungen aus
der deutschen automobilindustrie in
existenzielle nöte geworfen
die parteien haben das zu verantworten
und die cdu muss überlegen ob sie den
kurs des politik verwalten wie er vor
allen dingen von frau merkel praktiziert
wird weiter durchhält das bedeutet dass
sie sukzessive den weg der spd geht der
spd ist heute keine volkspartei mehr auf
die cdu wir diesen weg gehen oder ob sie
wieder inhalt stark wird ob sie wieder
kernig wird und dann wird sie
automatisch auch wieder ein geist in
sich haben an dem wir dann andocken
können und wo wir uns vielleicht dann in
zukunft auch mal als partner sehen
gut das werden wir abwarten birke im
phoenix-interview der landesvorsitzenden
thüringen und fraktionsvorsitzende im
thüringer landtag danke mich für das
gespräch